hi there Steve here you know my 90-day
challenge is drawing to a close I don't
know whether this day this is day 87 or
88 or what but and also Sunday I fly
back to Vancouver spend the Christmas
and New Year period there but today I
want to talk about just how much work it
is to become good in a language people
sometimes talk about all these polyglots
that speak all these languages and they
have a gift and all this other and it's
got it easy and people wonder why they
can't do it and stuff and I was thinking
today well yesterday I played golf I got
a call from a friend of mine from
Vancouver and he invited me out to play
golf and one of the people there was
someone who was six years younger than
me but went to the same school and grew
up on the same street and so we were
reminiscing a bit about Montreal in in
the early 50s mid 50s early 50s and I
just wanted confirmation from him I said
as I recollected you know we had French
from grade 1 grade 2 and we had it every
day and and yet most people couldn't
speak French in grade 11 or grade 12
after all of this exposure to French
that was my recollection and he said
yeah people can't couldn't speak French
and and I remember that I then went and
put a lot of work in the learning French
once when I went to McGill University
and I got so interested I would be
reading the newspaper and looking words
up in the dictionary and and watching
movies you know la nouvelle fog and kind
of half understanding not really
understanding and I just put so much
effort into the French a lot of effort
then I went lived in France for three
years as a student so I'm totally
immersed I had to do everything in
French University in France and in the
case of my Chinese you know I studied
for a year I worked seven eight hours a
day three hours one-on-one with the
teacher and then reading listening and
and then for a year and a half after
that I went in and out of China I went
to the
dontre fair twice a year and I had to
interpret for Canadian businesspeople
and I traveled to China and I saw I
spoke a lot and similarly with my
Japanese while I learned it on my own I
was in Japan I lived in Japan for nine
years I was constantly exposed to it and
again I would just devour all the books
that I could find which had glossary so
that I could somehow look words up that
I didn't know hoping that the words that
I didn't know were in the glossary very
often they weren't and so I put a lot of
effort into that and so I think about
that because I related back to my Korean
and actually I should say that I'm quite
amazed at how far I've come in Korea
because I hardly ever speak but I put in
a lot of this deliberate learning of
words and phrases through my listening
and reading so that I can understand now
these written the sort of transcripts of
these political podcasts following
events now in Korea where the president
is stepping down and there were million
people in the streets with these
candlelight parades and so forth and so
on and all of the infighting and back
fighting and the different political
parties and stuff and I can follow this
and you know I I don't it took me a long
time before I could follow any political
discussion in Japan watching television
and stuff even though I was immersed in
it and and of course those languages
that I speak the best are the languages
that I have spoken the most and I have
spoken about the Japanese a lot of
French a lot of Chinese through the
years similarly with Spanish traveling a
lot in Spain although less Spanish less
so you don't just pick it up now the
advantage I had with polish Ukrainian
was that after Russian and checked it
was easy to get to where you can
understand what you're listening to and
a lot of the words were the same so
that's not a fair comparison but Korean
a lot of the words are similar to
Chinese but they're kind of hidden you
have to find out which words they are so
it's not easy and so I was just thinking
that
in actual fact I've put a lot of effort
into those languages that I speak the
best and so actually where I am in
Korean and I'm just at the stage now
when I listen like I feel I'm gonna on
my last video I woke up my statistics I
said I was going to get from 30 thousand
known words to fifty thousand I think
I'm at 47 and I don't think I'll get to
fifty thousand but I said if I get to
fifty thousand I think that's where all
of a sudden I can understand what I'm
listening to
clearly because that was my experience
with cheque and with Polish and
Ukrainian I think it might take a little
longer in Korean because there's so many
words that are just a combination of
other words and so you know there's a
lot of words that maybe I don't really
know 50 thousand or maybe it's more
equivalent to thirty thousand or
something so but I'm almost there I can
just almost taste it when I'm listening
I'm getting more and more of the words
so I'm getting words maybe thirty forty
percent of the words I can understand
that when I hear them but like it is not
meaning for me when I listen to Korean
for exams is to Ukrainian I'm not
conscious of saying oh that's that word
and that's this word I understand that
word
it's just meaning like I could just as
well be listening to English I'm
following they're talking about
something having to do with politics in
the Ukraine and I follow exactly what
they're saying
I'm not dissecting what I'm listening to
whereas in Korean I'm still at the stage
or say wow you know I understood that
how does that or isn't that but the
whole thing together as an overall
meaning is still very fuzzy so I think
maybe I have to be at sixty thousand
word known words on my link count but
I'm not going to reach fifty within
another two days because there's just
too many other distractions here and
stuff but I want to stay with it because
you get this tremendous sense of you
know I just get you're almost there
you're at and and I believe when you get
to where you can understand what you're
listening to missing a few things then
you're well on your way to being able to
speak because I I always say I think the
the reading is where you acquire the
vocabulary because you can see it you
can save it ice it's highlighted in
yellow at Linc
by one I can review it so I'm
accumulating the vocabulary and I also
like listening to highlighting a phrase
and hearing the text to speak of that
phrase and I can also hear the
text-to-speech of individual words so
that's where I'm building up my
vocabulary but to get to where I can
speak well I've got to get to where I
can understand well and at the present
time I don't understand well I
understand when I speak to Hannah most
of the time simple content I'm very
familiar with the the context and stuff
but I want to get to where I understand
these political podcasts because that's
where I am at in my polish in my
Ukrainian and all these other languages
even Romanian which I hardly put any
effort into because so much of the
vocabulary is similar to Italian you
know on and or even the Slavic languages
20% of solve it so I'm going to stay
with my Korean there because I having
put so much effort into it and I think
this 90-day challenge it just forces you
guy there's no question that I would
never have put so much effort into it if
I didn't feel this obligation with the
90-day challenge it's been you know
three months it's been a long struggle
I'm really glad that I did it I sense
that I've improved a lot but I'm not yet
where I want to be so I will be
continuing after the end of the 90 day
challenge and I'll probably make one
more video sort of the final video of my
90 day challenge thank you for listening